we're back with Constance will y'all
give it up
that was a little bit of her new movie
Lila crocodile so your new movie is
based on the children's book is your
daughter a big reader she into it oh yes
I mean she can't read yet because she's
two but she is obsessed with books I
have to read her maybe 10 20 books every
night a day a day well a total a day but
at least 10 at night yeah oh my God am I
I'm like two and I like just one because
it takes a while to read through it do
you do voices I sometimes do voices I
actually don't do voices because the
goal is an actor well the goal is to get
them to fall asleep so I find oh I'm an
idiot soothing monotone voice yeah if
you just do it like this she starts like
a call map but maybe it's not working if
I'm reading 10 books I know maybe a new
approach you know
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]